as we know with the increase in the
online transaction and sharing of data
and information on the net create the
possibility of getting our data targeted
by cyber criminals who have malicious
intent
hi guys and welcome to yet another
interesting video by simply learn but
before we begin if you love watching
tech videos subscribe to our channel and
hit the bell icon to never miss an
update now everyone is aware how to use
an email as we share large amount of
personal and professional information
through it and now we think how exactly
can an email harm us
well that's what today we are going to
discuss about the topic for today's
video is email header analysis
through this video we'll be able to
analyze the mails that we receive on a
regular basis let's take a look at an
example of this email
what does everyone think about this mail
whether
this is a spam email or a non-spam email
well the answer of this question is it's
a spam email
and why is it so it's a content that we
are going to discuss further in the
video
now let's take a look at the agenda for
today
in this video we'll be learning about
what is an email to begin with we will
start briefly knowing what exactly then
email is
then we'll take a look how exactly an
email transfers from one point that is
the center point to the receiver point
then we'll also look at different key
parts that are involved in an email
and also what results involved in an
email attack
and then you come to the content that is
the most important in this video how to
analyze an email
then we'll see different parts of an
email header
and know the importance of email header
analysis
and lastly we'll see a demo how do we do
the email header analysis
let's begin
for the first topic we'll be knowing
what exactly is an email
let's start
an email is a way of sending and
receiving information through messages
which travel to different online
channels
which can not only contain text messages
but also photos and video data
which passes through different protocols
and servers to reach the receiver
mailbox
now that we have an idea what exactly is
an email
let's take a look at different servers
or different online channels that an
email goes through
to begin with the center will write a
message that is done through email
client known as apple mail or gmail and
send it through what is known as mta
mail transfer agent
this step is done through maintaining
different types of smtp protocols
the next step involves the transfer of
message in between different mail
servers which is done to the different
smtp protocols by this step a mail is
already in the recipient mail server
that is known as the mta
all these steps are done over the
internet
where the mail delivery agent also
checks whether the given email is spam
or non-spam which is done underway spf
that is known as the sender policy
framework
if the check fails then the given email
is termed as spam if not then the email
continues on its way for the receiver's
mailbox can be accessed by the receiver
and see the content of the mail
now that we have an idea how the mail
get transferred over different channels
and servers let's take a look what makes
up an email
for the first one we have
the email address which is one of the
most important part in an email
email address is a unique address that
is used for the delivery of messages
unless an email address is correct the
message that we transfer will not reach
its destination
then we have a part known as the body
section this part contains the actual
data that has to be transferred over the
net
to understand better we all have come
across different type of spam email
during regular times we often receive
different kinds of marketing spam or
different kind of institution spam that
explain us for different types of offers
that we can receive if we click on
different kind of links or visit
different kinds of websites
this is what is known as spam which is
nothing but unwanted mail or junk mail
then we have some individuals which use
emails for scamming people
the scam people of their personal
information or professional data
where they'll ask you to enter your bank
details or different login details to
complete a transaction to different
investment plans
last but the most dangerous risk
involved through email attacks is done
by professional hackers
they send hidden viruses or different
spyware programs in an email that are
nearly impossible to take during the
security protocols
when we open these emails the wireless
program gets installed into the system
and harms it
now that we have an idea about different
kinds of email and the risk involved
let's take a look how to analyze an
email
for the first step we have to access an
email to see the email header part
then we have to click on the more
section that is on the right most top
corner of the email
from there we click on the show original
option from the list now we can access
the email header section for an email
which will be used for the analysis
further in the video
now we will see what different parts are
involved during the analysis of an email
firstly we have what different basic
path comprises of an email header
in which we'll also see different fields
which is
return path dkim signatures
message id
mime version field
received field and the spam status field
let's take a look at them one by one
for first one we'll have different basic
fields that forms an email header
in which we have the form field which
shows from where we got the email that
is the sender's email and what the
sender name is
then we have what is known as the date
and time field which provides the date
and time stamp of the email received
then we have two part that depicts where
the system
will send the email to that is this
receiver's email
then lastly we have the subject field
which shows what is the topic that is
related to the email
now we'll understand what different
fields are important during the analysis
of an email
during the analysis the first field that
we have to see is the return path which
indicates if the email is bounced how
will it be taken care of that is
this address is different from the
sender's address and is specifically for
collecting and processing bounced emails
then we have is dkim signature this
field shows what different kinds of
authentication is required to identify
an email whether the email that has been
sent to us by the sender is the
authenticated version or it has been
tempered with
then we have a field that is known as
message id which is generated by the
first mta and also referred to as msa
mail submission agent which is a unique
combination of letters and numbers that
identify then email
and it is also different for each email
that is no mail can have the similar
kind of a message id
if such case arises there definitely is
a problem with an email
then we have what is known as the mime
version which is an indication of the
type of media or the content that has
been given in the body section of the
mail
it also provides a conversion standard
for media into text format to be
attached in an email as email can
consist of only text data
then we have the receive field which
shows email has reached its destination
and the email header is arranged in the
reverse order where the top shows the
last server which the mail went through
and the bottom the initial server
then we have the expand status
which indicates the spam score and the
threat level of an emu and if the
generated value crosses the maximum
output the email will be classified as
spam
now that we are clear about different
fields that are involved in an email
header let's see why is it important to
have an analysis of an email header
the importance of email header analysis
involves protection against spam and
phishing attacks due to several fields
that help us identify whether the given
email is spam or not and authentication
or not
then what we have is the identification
of the sender or receiver information
they allows us to authenticate whether
the receiver is the receiver or the
center's address matches the sender's
address
then lastly we have
what the tracking of an email we can
take a look what different servers or
online channels our mail went through
if there is tampered with different
types of channels or server in between
then definitely we can see there's a
problem with an email
now to understand what difference
between a spam email and normal email is
let's take a look at two different
fields
the first field that we have is spf
sender policy framework this field
allows us to identify how the spam email
is identified
this is the difference we can see that
in the normal mail we'll have a sign
which depicts
in front of all that shows that this is
a normal mail and in front of the spam
email we have a hyphen sign which
indicates this is a spam mail
the second field that allows us to
identify spam a normal email is dkim
they identify emails through the use of
different identification keys
if the keys matches for a normal email
and the sender email
then that is authenticated mail
if it does not it is termed as spam mail
now that we are clear about different
fields and what email is and of what
importance do email header analysis play
let's take a look at the demo for the
same
to understand the analyzing of an email
header better let's take a look at the
demo
in this demo we'll take a look at
different fields that are used for the
analyzing of an email
to begin with we'll take a look at an
example email
on the right top corner we will see the
more option
from which
we'll choose the show original option
after that in a new window will be open
with the email header part
this we see the message id field
that we discussed earlier in the video
that shows a unique form
of data of numeric and alphabetical
order to identify an email or
authenticate it
then we have created ad that contains
the timing
and the date part of the email
spf in short
is given as pass that means the email
that we received is somewhat safe
dkim signatures is used for the
authentication of an email
after this going below
we'll take a look at different fields
that we discussed
over here we have the return path
the received section
the date section
to
from field
and subject view
in this format we can't exactly identify
what different email headers are present
in the
raw form
to analyze this we will take a look at
different tools that are available on
the net
to do this we'll choose the option copy
to clipboard
and open a new window
and search for a
email header analysis tool which is
named as
mx analyzer
which is a popular email header analysis
tool
choosing this tool we'll go for the
analyze header part
and paste
the email raw form that we copied
and choose the option analyze header
and this is how the analyzed version
would look like
to understand better what exactly the
spam is let's take a look
through this we know
that a spam mail is not a problem
the problem lies with the dkim
authentication as we already discussed
in the video
dkim authentication is required to know
whether our email was stopped in between
during the transmission of different
servers
and on to the next form we have headers
delivered to header
the return path header
dkim signature header
and basic forms that require for the
identification of an email date to from
subject message id that we already
discussed in the video earlier
now that we know how to analyze an email
we can prevent the email spam email
phishing or different kinds of email
attacks
that are utilized by the hackers or
cyber criminals to steal our data and
harm our systems
now that we have an idea about how to
analyze an email let's take a look at an
email that was termed as spam by the
mail server
following the steps we did earlier
choose the show original option
and we'll have a new window with the
email header part
copying the clipboard
[Music]
going for a new window
and searching for the amnes analyzer
tool that will be used for the analyzing
the spam mail
analyze header option
paste your email header in the raw form
and analyze the header
with this we see the spf alignment does
not drop up
which means there is a problem with the
email
it might be interfered by a hacker or a
cyber criminal during the transfer of
the email through different servers
let's take a look
we can see that there is a t sign before
the all
that means as we already discussed in
the video
it indicates there's a problem with the
email
specifically
in the spam version
if the email was non-spam then the sign
that would have occurred over here
should be a hyphen sign before the call
this is how we differentiate whether the
security measures has been compromised
for an email or not
with this we have reached the end of the
module
if you have any questions you can ask
them on the comment section thank you
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here